we're seeing for the first time in
many decades a pandemic of this kind and
that's bringing out
also the the fact that stigmatization
can be a huge
problem in disease you've seen it in
nepal you've seen it in a couple of
european countries you've seen it in
korea
and japan countries like italy
and america you see a different kind of
stigmatization which is
a lot of it is directed towards the
chinese community
there are a few things that are
particular to perhaps south asian
countries slum areas for example they're
considered
sort of a hotbed of disease right in the
beginning of the pandemic in bombay
you had dharavi which is one of asia's
largest slums the government
frontline health workers when they went
back to their homes
in different neighborhoods they were
asked to leave because they knew they
were working in dharavi
we saw that healthcare workers were
attacked in haiti it happened in nepal
in iraq a 60 year old man who
um was sort of put in quarantine because
he had some symptoms he tested positive
he went into sort of institutional care
nearby
he came back to essentially what i was
told was an empty house
and a sort of deserted neighborhood i
was told that he actually committed
suicide
when you look at past diseases like
leprosy and hiv
i think those are much more stigmatized
diseases
leprosy is sort of the archetypal
stigmatized disease
where the associations are so ancient
even though you don't have much leprosy
today
still has that lingering association hiv
is more recent
and it's slightly different because hiv
is associated originally with
homosexuals
sex workers those were considered the
vulnerable groups
there's a certain amount of sort of
moral judgment
attached to that stigmatization was such
a problem the epidemic wasn't being
dealt with
perhaps most relevant uh from a public
health perspective
we've seen in past outbreaks that
if they if they fear or they anticipate
that they're going to be
ostracized or stigmatized in some way
a lot of people hide their disease
you're not getting health outcomes
because people
aren't adhering to treatment perhaps or
they're delaying care so that
you know more serious symptoms develop
and then they can't be treated or it's
much harder to treat them
the best data we have on this is from
hiv one analysis that they did
from 2011 to 2016 they found that
one in five people living with hiv
avoided going to medical facilities
because
they feared or anticipated being
mistreated marginalized groups
who are already sort of experienced
stigmatization within society
it sort of adds to that condition if
you're for example
a sex worker and you have hiv then
you're less likely to afford health care
you're economically perhaps not
as well-off and then and then you get
the disease so
there's what you call a compounding
effect
all the public health experts and
doctors say that you know you need to
communicate the science very well
um how transmission actually occurs what
is a virus
actually and sort of quash rumors
misinformation
sensationalism some people point to new
zealand as an example of good public
health messaging
people are not the problem here the
virus is the problem people are the
solution
there should be no shame and no blame in
contracting covert 19.
a lot of experts suggest that having the
media
also cover cases of recovery can be
really helpful
to to reduce fear
because now we're at least six months
into the pandemic i think that we see
that there has been some improvement
even in bombay there is a little less
fear
as you become familiar with the disease
and how it spreads
not as much as we need but certainly
there's been some improvement
and that certainly helped in being more
perhaps rational about
you know who to avoid when and how
it is going to go on for a long time so
we're going to have to see
how this plays out
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you